6 25 on your friday morning you know in
this season of graduations how about
some extra congratulations to a couple
of outstanding navy junior rotc students
from centennial high school
meet salome medina and catherine flaming
these two young women were awarded 200
000
each for full ride college tuition
scholarships in a ceremony in the
schools football field
salome's going to the university of san
diego catherine's going to notre dame
they'll both be commissioned naval
officers when they finish college
after some more formal photos salome and
catherine got to let out a little bit of
their excitement at this tremendous
achievement
congratulations again also four members
of the centennial staff were given what
they call impact influencer awards for
helping salome and catherine negotiate
the paperwork through that scholarship
application process if you know
something that's cool at school let us
know cool at school under the community
tab on our website or just email cool at
school eight newsnow dot com